we established that in coordinate
geometry if you want to describe a point
a single spot somewhere on the Cartesian
plane if you want to describe a spot
quite imaginary you want to describe a
point you use coordinates for example
three comma four they called coordinates
because you always have to have two of
them together that's when you see the
word coding it like cooperates or color
interior or codependent you got to be
there have you come together the three
in this case would be the x value right
that's where you are horizontally which
makes before the Y values where you are
they points coordinates what if you were
a whole bunch of points your collection
of points that are all on a line you
don't use coordinates Eddy war you use
an equation and this is an example of
one you got next you're going to wire in
there this is going to be a straight
line now we know about gradient when we
talk about points we learned our
y-intercept what does it align to set me
your line its y-intercept is what how
would you describe that yeah it's not
yeah this line is going to hit the
y-axis somewhere that is where it
doesn't okay so how we got that on to
this question I'm going to suggest to
start with we're going to think about
destroy your rock picture of this video
okay what we looked at earlier was if
you want to draw a wrong picture
probably the best way to go is actually
could find out your x and y intercepts
so for instance
for the x-intercept when we do this
equation to find the x-intercept I'm
gonna let something evil something else
Oh fantastic you might remember I
pointed this out it's a bit weird you
want to find the x-intercept
so you that y equals zero consarnit
remind me why that is why that is I
never said anything yet can tell me why
really can you tell me the reason for
this and this be different minutes
what's going on yeah next time is you
know very okay this happening so that
you may like to draw this idea your
Cartesian plane I'm about to find the x
intercept this is the x-axis everywhere
along the x axis you haven't gone up you
haven't gone down that means very clear
you're a dealer every single spot on the
x-axis has y equals zero so let's try
that I've got my question here 5x times
2 I plus 10 I'm going to substitute it
by 4 0 5 X minus 0 plus 2 how do you get
about the substations up good good ok
yeah what can I do with this I want X's
all the work of their own and this isn't
an immunity what I'm going to do to both
sides - I'm kind of subtract so now it's
a little thick 1 to 5 by 5 which gives
me okay so they're going to X equal
negative 2 I can go through my Cartesian
plane and I can go 1 2
that's an intercept so I'm going to put
a bit of an X there so I know I'm going
to go through this now the eighth step
so now the other thing you put is
cool let's do that just like that
instead of letting white with your I'll
add and X equal zero have a look what
can happen
zero minus two y plus 10 going to do the
same thing with that 10 I'm going to
subtract it from both sides and network
if I divide by is it I can divide by 2
but as legs went to mind by negative 2
that'll get me straight to be entered
once therefore so if I divide by
negative 2 what you just get positive 5
in it and then you cancel so again I'm
going to come back to my diagram I'm
gonna go one two three four five
that's where I'm going through so I've
actually added part of question here y
intercepts I understand that it's five
so I might just like that yeah we've got
that answer them but to get to the
gradients can quickly draw the actual
line by drawing the dots so that's what
it looks like okay put your pen down
familiar how can I use this to help me
find gradient do you see conveniently it
is a right angle triangle in there which
has a rise over run in it do you see it
yeah if I joined here in here there is a
right angle triangle the axes are always
perpendicular right so how do you
struggle to healthy this is rise over
here right what's the length it's like
because that's what the court it is and
I'm going up right just what they need
for you doing that what about the run
just now just look carefully I'm trying
to read from left to right okay so even
though this coordinate is there you to
the lengthier it's just - yeah so now I
can K therefore gray is right and run to
that
another two or two and a half which
Avenue to walk up to the right okay so
that sulphide is correct but a lot of
social inclusion into the fact that if
you want gradient and y-intercepts and
you've got the equation of a line you
think it's straight there no drawings
required if you get your light into
slope-intercept form does if you want to
remember what slope-intercept form is
I'll give you close it starts with Y you
can slide my good yeah very good
there that's the slope the gradient
that's the winner we chose our me I
don't know why the true speed but
whatever it's a convention that's pretty
consistent across people if I can change
this guy to look like this then I can
skip all of this work I can go straight
to the gradient a wider sense so now I
just over here or underneath if you're
still writing I'm going to start with
that equation okay
5x minus 2y by M equals zero and my job
now is to rearrange this equation so it
looks like this this form will just tell
me straight away what the gradient
light-sensing are - MX plus take the
subject of the equation is 1 1 that's
the thing I want to get by itself so
then you look at this I've got all this
stuff over here on the Left I need to
get to stuff from the left over to the
right which sucks I need to get rid of 5
and 10 so what should I do besides
I should subtract right I'm going to say
this again it's not just that I'm moving
them over there because they're not
going to be 5x plus 10 over there are
there going to be minus 5x minus 10 okay
so much like that this might have to why
I haven't touched it at all it's still
there over here I've got minus 5x minus
10 moving maybe positive too much I
haven't touched the most - like it
stayed on the left yeah or going ahead
now I didn't need to do one more thing
to this line to turn it into this I
don't want the matter to why I just what
Y so what will I do it size
I'll divide by negative two just like I
did okay it's the same deal right so I'm
going to divide everything by negative
two okay I just watch Africa so this is
going to become minus 5x on negative -
yeah - 10 on negative two divided
everything don't miss out any 30 equals
now I just want to tidy this up a little
bit
I've already done most of the legwork I
just want to make it look neat I'm Jade
is 5 negative 2 this thing is on the top
of the bottom what can I do with those
guys I can cancel them and I'm going to
write the 5 over 2 by itself just like
the air that is by itself over there and
is that right do so you don't have to
you can write that as 5 X 1/2 if you
like but this just kind of put right up
front set up that's the thing that I
want at the foot that's the provision a
lot of material it's 5 over 2 times X
now what happens over here again the
native kids so don't they leaving you
with plus 5
ok now what should you compare that
amount of work with this amount we had
to like do both into touch we have to
get drawing and think about this and
then we've got another side okay clearly
this is much more efficient if you know
what you're doing if you know where
you're going okay questions read a wire
line then the three is the word so again
look do you think we actually work this
out right here so I'm just reading up
looking here is M this is the gradient
or the slope right and then with the
y-intercept it's over here
we already found it so this is just
verifying that we got it right this is
the one set okay which is work lately
one two way you do medication from Zack
now this form doesn't give you the X
except another pulse we'll get to those
but what is hands to you is okay now if
I gave you some other random equation if
I said to you y equals mu
or X plus 2 we need to find any
x-intercept once I can go through all
that legwork
you can already straightaway say the
gradient is negative 4 so it's if there
is that maybe it's going down and the 4
tells you some pretty steep where is
profit like rock but what does that tell
you the y intercept will be on my graph
that I'm just going to hijack I'm here
to correct so this would look something
like we said much tape right something
like that there you go that'd be y
equals minus 4 X plus 2 you can look at
this you can read the pages directly off
it which is why we call it sloping
simple okay